hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen I'm a new mama and let me
tell ya the struggle is real
and one of the things that has really
surprised me as being super difficult in
motherhood is breastfeeding honestly
kill me I've spent so many hours in the
middle of the night googling how to
increase my milk supply and I always
come up with basically the same list of
these so-called breastfeeding foods now
being a science minded person obviously
I had to do my research and I've done a
lot of reading and I haven't found any
really good strong legit research to
suggest that any of these foods really
do improve your milk supply but having
said that they're all super delicious
and they're all really really good for
us and as breastfeeding mamas we just
need more nutrition in our day not to
mention when you put them all together
into a cookie recipe they are so good
you don't even care what they're for hey
I say Mama's you deserve all the cookies
that you want so today we are going to
be making my favorite gluten-free vegan
lactation friendly cookies that are so
delicious
even the daddies are gonna want some so
let's do this
to a bowl I add some gluten-free rolled
oats lutein free all-purpose flour
brewers yeast ground flaxseed cinnamon
nutmeg ground ginger baking soda salt
and some baking powder and I give that a
good stir till it comes together then to
my stand mixer i soften up some vegan
butter then I add some light brown sugar
and cream them together until smooth
next I add some natural almond butter
some flax eggs and some vanilla and
process that until it's nice and creamy
I add my wet ingredients to my dry
ingredients and then I give everything a
good stir until it forms a nice dough
[Music]
finally it's time for our add-ins I add
some sliced almonds some dark chocolate
chunks and some candied ginger and give
everything a good stir
roll them into balls and place them
about an inch apart on a baking sheet
sprinkle them with a little bit of fleur
de sel and then pop them into a 350
degree oven for about 20 minutes
[Music]
and enjoy
well guys I hope you enjoyed this recipe
for my lactation cookies hopefully your
boobs are feeling extra full today and
hey even if they don't really do
anything for your breast milk supply
they're delicious and that is reason
enough to indulge well guys if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below some of your
ideas for increasing your milk supply
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
you